there's a thought process that inflation
is merely the act of stealing wealth
from the poor and enriching the elite
and wealthy right and so what that means
is if you have paycheck to paycheck and
you leave a high percentage of your net
worth in cash then every year you're
losing value or you're losing purchasing
power but if you actually have other
assets and a lot of them inflation
continues to drive the price of those
assets up and therefore those that own
non-cash assets actually benefit
drastically from inflation and are
incentivized to keep the party going
right and so if you switch to a
deflationary model actually the people
with the preference to have a high
percentage of their net worth in the
currency will benefit drastically and
those in non-cash assets will actually
not benefit in this scenario for sure
and I like to describe Bitcoin and sort
of this entire sort of phenomena as a
grand wealth transfer event and I
believe that it will be arguably the
single biggest wealth transfer event in
human history it will be a wealth
transfer from the old to the young from
the tech savvy to sort of the more
conservative from the open-minded sort
of the more closed-minded and of course
from the people who will be holding
these crypto assets and most of all
Bitcoin in the losing side in this case
would be people holding fiat currencies
gold etc absolutely so let's say that
everything you've described is true
right and this is and you just laid out
the blueprint for how this is gonna play
out over the next decade two three four
decades right how big is the opportunity
right what is the market cap of Bitcoin
ten or twenty years from now
so so like before before I answer that
question I'll say that as Bitcoin let's
say in six to eight years from now as it
it's a bit bigger much more volume much
more Linde effect much more trust much
more credibility etc much more
mainstream people will simply compare to
things and Bitcoin will be in a
free-market battle against fiat
currencies and gold simultaneously and
even other things when you just isolate
the store value component as we have
discussed people will simply say okay
this thing is expanding at 6% per year
in its supply and this thing is
expanding at 1% per year in its supply
which one should I pick as a store of
value and that's why to me so that this
feedback loop is inevitable it will be
so difficult to stop the math becomes
undeniable it's it is really if you sort
of extrapolate this phenomena and
extrapolate this sort of wave of
financial change Bitcoin will be a black
hole that will absorb a tremendous
amount of value I believe the total
addressable market is somewhere between
100 and 200 trillion I like to say it
will be a hundred and sixty trillion so
if Bitcoin and that is if we go off of
the ten million dollars per Bitcoin
price in today's terms without even
counting the sort of the inevitable
hyperinflation of fiat currencies and so
this is my reasoning so - you think that
a single Bitcoin will be worth ten
million dollars in today's money mm-hmm
yes I do and which would give us a
market cap of what like a hundred
hundred and sixty trillion right now the
current market cap of Bitcoin is 110
billion I believe when this bear market
is done give or take will bottom some
around eighty billion and so that's a
2000 X that is still possible between
right now and what is probably our death
and I think like that is there's still a
tremendous opportunity here and I think
high net worth individuals a more sort
of edgy open-minded tech-savvy
institutions and eventually government
institutions will will push this
to the extreme these are big numbers
you're talking and you realize that very
few people in the world believe what you
believe right now I realize that but if
you spend sort of months and months
studying this it sort of becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy to you I'm very
confident I'm very confident Bitcoin
will be bigger than the US dollar and
potentially even bigger than all of them
combined because there's a interesting
table that Vijay boy a party has made
and he says that crypto currencies or
Bitcoin in particular are harder to tax
harder to seize easier to transfer
easier sort of harder to steal easier to
sort of cheaper easier faster to send
around the world they are borderless
they are sort of uber competitive
they're highly deflationary it's such a
and there's like there's dozens and
dozens of reasons and all of these
combined I believe will make Bitcoin
incredibly big similar to what the gold
standard was in the late 19th century
but given the fact that the economy is
much bigger today and given the fact
that it is digital and sort of much more
fluid I believe it will be far far
greater than even that and yeah that's
mine these are my thoughts absolutely so
let's talk about this idea of
hyperinflation and the fiat currency
experience our experiment right so 1971
was it Richard Nixon right takes us off
the gold standard the gold standard
being the thought process that for every
paper currency every US dollar you could
go and redeem the equivalent in gold
right it was being held in the central
banks at the time what a lot of people
don't realize is Richard Nixon said
we're gonna go back to the gold standard
it was a temporary decision right or at
least asked how they was presented and
so we obviously didn't and since 1971
what we have seen across the world at
different times in different locations
is fiat currencies start to fail right
and these fiat currencies where they
appear to be failing most is in
regions or countries where a government
or the overseeing organization loses
discipline right and the thought process
is in the developing world we have much
more discipline right there's checks and
balances and the Fed can't press the
print button too much right because
there's those checks and balances but in
let's say a country where a dictator
comes into power there's less checks and
balances there's a higher probability
that they will lose discipline that you
can hit the print button too much and
you get into hyperinflation devaluing of
the currency and we know how that ends
right let's talk about that
hyperinflation period why are we seeing
this in the countries we're seeing it
today right and do you think that this
is gonna happen to every fiat currency
in the world why or why not I believe
it's a combination of incompetence as
well as outright grasping for power okay
and I do believe that this will
eventually happen to all fiat currencies
around the world but it will happen sort
of stage by stage of course the second
and the third world currencies will be
the first to collapse and sort of the
more established euro and dollar the
leak from sort of the the financial leak
from there to towards Bitcoin will be a
bit more gradual it will be more like an
s-curve and then it will reach a point
where the money will just like rapidly
flowing rapidly flow into Bitcoin
because people will as I've described
people will simply realize that this
money is harder than the other one the
other money there's people behind it and
these people can do whatever they want
however this is governed by such a
strong unbreakable algorithm and the
community of people sort of
strengthening it that the the I believe
the sort of the credibility and the
faith and the trust in Bitcoin relative
to fiat currencies will keep growing and
as I've said in the beginning currencies
and sort of the cognitive monetary
premia that's placed atop them is first
and foremost is about trust and it's
about credibility Swiss the Swiss franc
for example people like it because the
Swiss don't print too much
they they have sort of three hundred
years of credibility they have they have
temperance they have disciplined as
you've described a lot of sort of and
it's important a safety in a moose in in
his work he often says that
hyperinflation has never occurred with
metals because there are natural limits
to creation and there are natural sort
of free-market balances there but it's
in 99% of cases it has occurred with
fiat currencies because they are at the
behest of humans and joerger to Huisman
who's arguably the most prominent
Austrian economist today in the world he
says that sort of this money supply
inflation has traditionally been the
means of financing war but as of late it
has become it's not just used in in
wartime it's been being used perpetually
and I like to say that so this inflation
it essentially shifts some activity from
long term projects and long term capital
goods production to more sort of
short-term consumption I'm a believer
that it is not the consumption that
really drives the sustainable long term
growth of the economy the kind that
actually increases our quality of life
but rather us engaging in long term
projects long term capital goods
production long term production of tools
instruments research innovation and
things like that and really the best
things that have you ever been created
they were 10 20 30 year efforts rather
than sort of us going and buying
something useless right and so I believe
that if we have a currency that's more
deflationary well people will be
incentivized instead of thinking instead
of going out there and as you've
described investing into something else
or even buying like a pack of crisps or
just new shoes or really something
that's really useless right now instead
people will be just due to the
deflationary nature of it it will be
seen and felt as more precious people
will be more incentivized to eight save
and be invest in long-term projects and
a long term sort of craft